you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this is
the incredible Felipe Esparza who is a
incredible standup comedian he won Last
Comic Standing he also has just a very
very interesting story and is a good and
funny and kind and nice guy and I'm
really glad you guys are here to listen
in on our conversation only a couple
things to plug up top if you go to Pete
homes.com you'll see that I am going to
be in Los Angeles on May 4th May the 4th
uh it's going to be with us uh go to P
homes.com that's the Netflix is a joke
festival at the Wilshire Eble Eble
theater uh and also my tickets to
Chicago are on there I'm also going to
be we're I'm going to make sure this is
added I'm going to be also in La at the
not the Brea Improv the Irvine Improv so
we'll add tickets uh to pet homes.com uh
I'll be at Largo on January 30th as well
if you like the show and you want to
support it why not try a petza pick uh
one of them modern mammals I talk about
this constantly modern mammals is the
only shampoo that I found that cleans
your hair but doesn't look like you
shampoo shoed your hair cuz let's be
honest when you shampoo your hair it
looks like absolute [__] it looks like a
bail of hay that you toss in a dryer
gets crisped it gets unruly it looks
terrible usually if I had a TV
appearance or an important uh event
where I had to look good my strategy was
I wouldn't wash my hair for two three 4
days leading up to it so it have some of
that natural moisture some of that hold
now modern mammals can clean my hair my
hairdresser used to complain cat my
friend that my hair was dirty that it
was gross and it was cuz I wasn't
cleaning it cuz I didn't want it to look
like crap modern mammals cleans your
hair but it maintains that natural hold
and that some of that oil and some of
that I don't know how to explain it it
keeps it looking great it's almost like
you have product in your hair almost
like a dry shampoo but when you wash it
it looks as good as it can so there have
only are got 40,000 guys that have
switched to Modern mammals instead of
traditional shampoo once you use it you
will be hooked for life I tell people
about it all the time it's a small
Grassroots punk rock company I
absolutely love it they have bars for
the no plastic version with no fragrance
or bottles which is like a magic gray
mud that I love the feeling and the
smell of that gets your hair perfect
every single time 6 seconds to perfect
hair go to Modern mammals.
comom weird where people can get a
special combo be deal and try both
products the bar and the bottle for 44
bucks that lasts a really really long
time so 44 bucks for both you'll be set
for a while and your hair will look
perfect and won't look like absolute
[__] shampoo sucks go to Modern mammals
uh also we're brought To Us by another
piece of uh technology I guess you could
call modern mamal technology if there's
one piece of actual Tech that has
changed my life more than any other in
the past year
it is hands down my Apollo neuro which
I'm wearing right now I'm always wearing
it when I do late night when I do stand
up what is it it's a wearable piece of
tech that helps your body recover from
stress that sends vibrations into your
body sending a signal to your nervous
system that gives it the sensation of
being held or touched it's like a
wearable virtual hug that helps calm and
regulate your nervous system it can help
you relax sleep focus and be more
productive I was just writing before I
did this intro I had it set to focus
which they have the data to back helps
fight off symptoms of ADD it's a
wearable hug using touch therapy to help
you feel safe and in control you can
wear it on the wrist like I do or on
your ankle helps me fall asleep and stay
asleep at night in fact that's a new
feature that they've updated that it
will sense when you have woken up and
rerun the program without you even doing
anything so sometimes I'm awake in the
night and I'll just notice my apoll is
turned back on and it lulls me back to
sleep rebuild and recover wonderful for
after you've been stressed calm which is
wonderful for meditation unwind which is
what I put it on when I'm watching TV at
the end of the day to help me prepare
for bed it's wonderful for energy focus
sleep relaxation it is a GameChanger and
a lifechanger devel developed by a
neuroscientist and a board certified
psychiatrist who've been studying the
impacts of chronic stress in humans for
nearly 15 years Apollo's effects on
stress sleep cognitive performance and
Recovery have been proven in multiple
clinical trials and real world studies
so this is not a mood ring this is not a
crystal this is hard science 10% off go
to apollon neo.com weird get one for
yourself get one for a friend it's a
wonderful gift we've given many as gifts
10% off a p o l l
n.com weird all right everybody enjoy
Felipe espara I like this I like what
I'm looking at yeah my wife got this for
me the whole suits yeah oh it's a suit
you didn't match it it came together
yeah feder colia
Colombiana football I like the could you
take it off if you're not colan I'm just
kidding you know second you were like I
thought that man really I met a man at
the airport I thought he was going to
say that take it off yeah cuz he go
Colombiano I said no Mexico I'm Mexican
and he said oh okay I like it
oh he was okay with it they're great
colors yeah I like the whole thing and
did the shoes you pick those out no I
didn't my wife got the whole outfit she
did the whole thing yeah she do that
with you yeah she dressed you I mean
like in general is that like a thing in
your relationship she has a lot of um I
have a lot of tracksuits that are what's
going on with the watch I was just
looking at this watch that's a nice
watch thank you man come on Felipe tell
me about that watch you a watch guy
no no
you know it's funny cuz no I work with
um I got an
email no I got a text from comedian um
Eddie Griffin yeah and he and he he saw
one of my Ros he wanted to be on a show
but and I thought it going to be like to
open maybe open in the show but not he
want to be in the show with him and Gary
Owens and like a standup show Gary Owens
and DL hugley and um Cedric Entertainer
whoa I was in the same bill with them
you know it already happened it already
happened and I he and then I went to I
went to everybody's green room to talk
to them and the hugly said what kind of
watch is that and I said um filston yeah
and then he go
Filson he said Filson and um never heard
of it and I said I know um so old
company they don't exist no more they
were bought by um by another company
um was a CH sh shook or I wouldn't know
it's like a old reference when um he
don't know something from sh oh sh Shola
Shola yeah yeah yeah so Shola is a
company and they bought this company I I
guess and now they make that yeah this
is one where did you get it though I I
bought it off the internet oh you did
buy it yeah I have two of them you like
it I like it I thought I thought the
story is going to end and then Eddie
Griffith gave you that watch no but
Russell Peters comedian he gave me two
watches Russ one of them crazy generous
isn't he I did a he did this podcast I
went to his house and I think he meant
it he was like if you're ever here just
text me and I'll let you in the house
and you can just hang out of the house I
was like what but I think he meant it
yeah when I opened up for him in Canada
I was there for for a month I went um
shopping with him and he was like um
Chiller Swift over there oh yeah they
were all over him
like everybody was he needed a security
was it brown Canadians or just Canada in
general cuz I know he's huge in the
Asian it was like me walking into East
Los
Angeles like like the one come on in
taste our food where my
daughter that's fantastic can't get up
no more please help me you know what's
crazy is so in prep for the interview or
this conversation it's not interview
it's not Barbara Walters yeah that's for
you what is it shake it up and drink it
what is it for us it's got caffeine
neotropics and uh adaptogens it helps
you calm down and picks you up about as
much caffeine as half a cup of coffee
it's called Magic mine is like a do that
milk in it no it's just green tea little
bit of agave it just shoot it man T good
it tastes great but it'll make you uh
happy that sounds like somebody just
gave you drugs it'll make you
happy you don't have to like the taste
oh man your face didn't like the T
taste to like
nightquil it's more of a
Al yeah but it it's it's not a sip and
enjoy it's like you'll like how you feel
in 10 minutes or you let me know I don't
it's not like drugs right I'm like sober
no no no it's not it's nothing I
wouldn't have given that to you yeah you
were in rehab for something what was
that I was in rehab when I was like a
young adult like late teens early 20s
late teens so when did you get into
introduced um I started drinking since I
was 15 really my mom and dad they would
have um parties at my uncle's house that
there was always beer around and you
just drink we just sneak my brother and
I would sneak a little beer and take it
with my cousins and it would we'll pass
it around oh no to were kids and then I
ended up um just drinking um 40 o yeah
that's Malt Liquor Malt Liquor yeah cuz
where I lived there was a a a a little
market and the guy didn't car nobody
really no he would we would just go in
there and just buy 240s
and no ID no [__] no nothing um kids
will come in and with a little note sell
my daughter a pack of marble cigarettes
she's eight and they would just sell it
to her because maybe that happened
honestly once and now it's just a scam
yeah yeah oh that's that's crazy so
booze was the one that got you yeah
booze and then later on I started doing
other stuff around 15 no when I was 20
20 yeah so take me through that like
when did it start becoming by the way
this is in the interest of healing it's
not like a page six gossip thing but
here you are I'm just so impressed with
your life and everything you're doing so
it's very interesting you immigrated
from Mexico I know that story took three
tries yeah and then you got into Los
Angeles East Los Angeles Bo Heights
actually okay I think it was Bo Heights
cuz it was off five freeway yeah okay by
SoDo Street General Hospital and what
was what was your life like that you
felt you know that alcohol was trying to
fix something you know what I mean I I
didn't really like think about it like
that no I know but now that you're a
grown man yeah but was were you stressed
as a kid was there something or was it
just boring this B be getting to my head
man what is this spelling be is getting
to my head this teacher keep busting out
these pop
quizzes me something had to be grinding
at you I just felt that was everybody
look happy so I want to be cool too you
just wanted to fit in but then it got it
it's like hooking you like you have the
allergy yeah man I remember um living
with a girlfriend and she said you
better not drink and I said okay and I
would um I would go in the bathro and
lock the door and po up a bath and then
chill inside with a a
sixpack listening to
NWA that that should be a screen
saver Felipe in a bubble bath hiding
from hisf hid from his girlfriend in the
bathroom right right so it wasn't just
it it went pretty quickly from being
something fun and cool to something you
needed right I mean you tell me it
sounds like that sounds like somebody
that's like
not a casual I never thought about it as
something I needed just felt like
something I wanted to do yeah like I
remember um being three days sober and
goes man I for like I could conquer the
world again and I go back to being drunk
yeah and what I mean it just too
uncomfortable to not or you just liked
it I liked it yeah I miss when did it
start being a problem like what was the
moment where you were like this is not
cool I guess when um I started fighting
with people you were an aggressive kind
of drunk yeah I would like get not
violent but like I remember like it's
like if somebody told me something like
5 years ago and I was like didn't have
the confidence or to fight him or
approach him then I would see him now
hey man remember 5 years ago you were
talking a lot of [__] in fifth grade now
you'll confront them if no when I was
drunk oh when you were drunk You' look
them
up so you'd start getting in fights yeah
it was dumb fights too because like I
remember this guy came out of prison he
must have been in prison for like 10
years and they used to call him
Batman that was his name Batman really
his real name was Steve Steve
right well Bruce you so and I'm hanging
out with my friends I must be like 19
years old 20 and he passes by he's like
in his 30s he just come out of
prison and my friends are like what's up
Batman and he he go what's up
man they nah man this
Batman he's Batman too you yeah he was
cuz they were telling him what's up man
and go not you this Batman right
here he get mad this is the problem and
he came over here wish Batman then he
point at me this one he man he wanted to
fight over the name wow and I said now
man I told him we're not going to fight
over a name we're just going to
fight he said that like Javier
barend we're just going to fight we're
just going to fight I'm going still be
Batman and you could Contin still be
Batman I'm not going to fight for no
stupid
name and then you just fought yeah is
that was a thing you just you got in
fights yeah he was drunk and I was drunk
so it was like a short fight yeah H you
know I had father Greg Bole on the pod
that's part of how I know about you oh
yeah he's a good man I helped him he
helped me yeah I used to when he I knew
him before I when I was sober too when I
was a young teenager oh really um a lot
of my friends that I have that I have
now I have a friend that works for um
Southwest Airlines in Burbank Joe
Baron and him and him and I we we head
it off because he goes hey um father
Greg baptized me in in uh Juvenile Hall
so that how we became friends but I I
grew up in a in the same neighborhood
where father Greg Bo was a Jesuit priest
yeah and I remember when he was when I
was like a little kid I saw in a
newspaper clip that he was caught by the
Contra in South America I guess
somewhere Nicaragua and Salvador yeah
and um as soon as they found out who he
was they blindfolded him and they
dropped him off somewhere in a
jungle and they call the authorities and
told them where to find him and no way
they let him go wow that's uh it's funny
it's hard to get father Greg to brag but
if I was him I'd brag like he tell he
tells stories that like they'd be like a
driveby or something and all the homies
jump on him like the Secret Service to
protect him and I'm like that is so
incredible that that people love you
that much but you'd never meet a more
humble person like imagine if a comic
was like I was kidnapped by you know
terrorists in the jungle but when they
found out who I was they just let me go
I mean that You' never hear the end of
it but that's not even one of his top 10
stories yeah when I when I saw when I
knew him it was before he had um homeboy
industry it was called um jobs for the
future future yeah um nothing stop with
the the logo Nothing Stops a bullet like
a a bullet like a job I said like a gun
like and I remember watching um what was
that show with Gary shanin Larry Sanders
Larry Sanders and one of the writers
came in wearing a homeboy industry shirt
oh really yeah the original one it was a
black one with a red and red white and
green letters yeah and it said homeboy
in this I oh there it is that's crazy I
wonder if Gary knew them and loved them
I mean that's that's it was a it was a
rider that he that was a regular writer
on the show yeah he would always fight
with him yeah about jokes yeah it was
that writer but I thought that was cool
but of all the so I listen to Father
Greg's books constantly I just love them
so much and today on the ride down I was
like oh I'll listen to one and there's
three of them and they're each about six
hours long you know six hours of him
audiobook so I put on one at random and
I hit play so this 18 hours of him
talking the one that I hit play on he
quotes you what are the chances I'm
driving to talk to you it's in the whole
language it's like chapter nine or
something so right in the middle and he
goes as Felipe Esparza says gangs aren't
all bad they carpool yeah and I was like
what are the
chances dude I'm driving to meet you and
that was what came on I was like this is
that's a synchronicity that was crazy
there's nothing good about gang banging
it said they all they all carpool yeah
they're like come on homie get in here
let's all get caught
I I remember I did a birthday a birthday
show for him in the morning at homeboy
industry and I remember I was like
really it was more like a roast of
homeboy industry yeah the way they work
and the way they operate and everybody
was laughing I remember I Tred to get a
job here at homeboy industry and and
they interviewed me and they asked me um
you ever been shot no he goes you ever
been in the gang no he goes you ever
been in jail no okay man you don't me
the
qualifications so I went out there and
got shot two times went to prison they
gave me the keys to the
truck it is like an upside down World in
that way I was with my wife we're trying
to buy
um merchandise we're trying to start our
own merch for to sell at the end of the
show so we went to Homeboy Industries
skill um S screen yeah and um it R it's
run by a old friend of mine that grew up
in a neighborhood named named
Reuben and he wasn't there but his um
nephews was there and some other kid I
recognize because my mom used to babysit
his older brother when they were little
but now he's this big 6'2 gang banger
and they're taking our order we're
talking and then these four other dudes
come in and they were wearing masks like
handkerchiefs like bank robbers you know
like in the 1800s they sck it up yeah
yeah yeah and wearing um hats and and
sunglasses and I thought they were part
of the crew that works somewhere in the
back in the warehouse and they got real
Dusty right they came in Dusty and I and
then they came in there and they
looked and I looked that there goes man
you guys should get
some some some
um some what they call some for their
nose or faces what they called um you
like a a full mask yes you better mask
for these guys cover up your whole face
these guys look
weird anyways so when they left the guy
that was helping us he was gone
everybody was gone they came there to
shoot somebody oh no yeah they were
there to shoot somebody they came in
there and said they looked around and I
didn't know then I Then I then I went
through like Facebook oh yeah somebody
was shot where I used to live by the
Rival
of where my Elementary School used to be
W so they were they were there to kill
somebody and they saw my wife with white
blonde hair blue eyes and they saw my
stepson four years old playing with his
car on the floor they said oh man
there's white people here man every
better not shoo nobody here is that real
yeah cuz that's one of the most I'm
thinking they said oh [__] there's white
people here right he goes he go this
this they're going to add more char to
our crimes now so my God and and I think
one of the guy who recognized me from
the neighborhood cuz they came when they
came in I just said what's up fool and
they went about their business they left
and then I I made a I said I told him
man you should I told the guy you should
call all the other places where you have
gang banger working at and tell them hey
man these guys came in man I don't think
they were looking for jobs
right it wasn't like uh in the good way
yes yeah that's crazy but I mean who
working not I'm not trying to be funny
who working there couldn't think of
somebody that might an enemy like who
doesn't have an enemy know that's one of
the tense things about this life that's
what I was kind of that's that's in that
that's one of the that's one of Father
gra Bo's books too how these guys are
working with enemies every day right
right they used to shoot bullets now
they shoot texts yeah and that's what's
so beautiful about it cuz a gang is a
group group it's really hard to change a
group but an individual that's I was
just listening to it he's like that you
invite into a new group he's like you
can't like just take the idea out of
someone's head you give them a new idea
and a new group and a new identity I
think that all the time it's like groups
I can't [__] with groups it's too much
you know what I mean we're forming an
entire group but if you give one guy you
know what I mean did you see that movie
Green Book I talk about all this all the
time greenbook is a white racist
dude is hired to drive the black guy
yeah and by the end of the trip guess
what he's not racist anymore you know
what I mean see that's an individual you
know what I mean like I can't make every
white dude or Italian or whatever he is
in the in the 70s not racist but like
one guy on a car trip and that seems to
be like the homeboy way it's like come
in here let's just talk to an individual
I don't want to know about your your
neighbor where you're from or whatever
we just want to talk to one heart and
that seems to be be part of the strategy
what do you mean when when he helped you
what was that Greg father Greg oh Father
Greg um he didn't have a car yet I mean
he had a car but it it belonged to other
per other priest he was just cruising
with on a beach cruiser so he was
driving around 3: in the morning
remember beach cruiser yeah on the bike
and a
bicycle and my mother must have called
for the great boyo cuz I know I didn't
and he came to my house why what was she
what was going on that she was like this
guy needs a priest I was going I was
like drinking too much at this time now
and I got into a lot of fights yeah with
more Batman and Joker and
Peng are you getting hurt in these
fights are these serious fights I'm
getting hurt man you're getting hurt
hospital no just busted eye you know I'm
but your mom's worried about you
bleeding
nose just a black guy all the time a
black guy constantly with a black guy
isn't that really if you're growing up
in are you in a neighborhood with gang
activity isn't it tricky what if
Batman's in a group there's gang
activity but the most of the fights that
are that are H that happen inside like a
a neighborhood where there's usually one
gang everybody just fights amongst each
other oh really yeah like they might be
a TW a gang part of the gang that's 19
years old and 20 they're like a newer
gang that's in the gang but then you got
people who are in their 20s and 30s then
people who are in their 40s and 50s who
are a different generation you put them
all together and there's alcohol there's
always a
fight that's got to be a trip to be in a
gang for 30 years my friend who sobered
35 years he's from a gang called White F
uhhuh from East Los
Angeles and then there's another white
FS there's two white friends white
friends are like the oldest gang in Los
Angeles they've been around since the
30s you know and they they had a a
reunion like a reunion of all the
original guys
in and um my friend um he's been so he's
been a sober 35 years and he went to the
reunion and he goes what happened oh I
had to leave early what why H it's a big
fight yeah he go what happened oh some
some here the way he said it some CER
didn't like that they were in the
invitation and all hell broke loose W
and it was mean that one like one part
of the gang like a click was not
mentioned in the invitation oh so there
was like a a dispute between the older
guys see it is like running a this is
what he told Corporation or something
like there's there's feelings it's like
who gets invited who gets s it's like
planning a wedding or something it's
like who gets the honor and all that
stuff so it's this thing that seems so
you know straet or what whatever but it
has these similarities to like the
McDonald's quarterly Christmas party you
know what I'm saying even if you make
stuff up people like I remember you know
how every year that they have um they
have that big concert in the desert um
burningman not burning man the other one
where all like three days I looked to
Katie Coachella Coachella she was like
all rock you know one is Rock then
there's another one that happened later
on it's all country Stage Coach yeah but
I made a of Coachella but like um all um
every Latin comedian I can think of I
put it this night headlighting George
Lopez you know and and I put um another
comic second night gabri glaas third
night Fool's gone wild you know and I
was I put myself in then I put a any
every type of comedian that would be in
the George Lopez show you know like that
I could think of from Texas from Puerto
Rico anybody that's Latino and I put
them all there then I put the with the
Gabriel one everybody with that he might
be comfortable working with you know I
put Angela Johnson you know I put um a
list right then I put the the Fool's
gone wild George Perez me K FL um Ral
Barbosa you know and all these
names people in the comment started
complain man this guy shouldn't be on
that list
why what do you mean he shouldn't be in
my makeup list where I made up in my
hand you made up list you're saying the
politics extend to Comedy as well he go
oh Mia call Mia shouldn't be on day two
he should be on day five and I'm like
bro there is no day five exactly and
people are arguing on it I took it down
it's make believe yeah yeah yeah you're
fighting I took down my make believe
post cuz I was getting serious mad
comments
how were the shows but I thought huh
were the shows good there was no show I
just made it up I mean but did it happen
never oh it never happened was pretend
made it up it was that pretend it was a
fake Co the whole thing was fake the
whole thing was fake dude I thought it
was real but the list you're like the
list cuz I saw like um I saw a l the
fake coella list you just go look up the
app and go um fake Coachella list and
then you start putting your own bands
your own preference so I saw one that
this night will be Hulu and they had all
the Hulu shows so I you know what I'm
going do one with Latin Comics so then I
put them this night this guy be
headlining then a bunch of younger
comics on the bottom man me and my
friend we we actually work hard on this
fake
list we put in like 3 hours trying to
find names and still people are mad and
then people that were not on it were
like oh man I should have been on it
dude that's like there was that website
the 100 top standup comedians you
remember that it was a joke but I know
people that were like checking where
they are I'm like no it's a joke it's a
joke the whole thing's a joke but we
still looked at it we want to be on the
list man yeah or like when um also when
um Like a Rolling Stone comes up with a
top 100 Comedians and everybody somebody
watching all the same 10 people yeah um
Sarah
Silverman all these people all her and
all her friends yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then mad DAV to and all these people
well lists are it's funny when I watch
my daughter playing and she excludes
someone you know she doesn't want to
play she's five so let's say there's a
younger kid this is normal there's like
a baby you know when babies stop being
babies they immediately turn on babies
babies hating babies and I'm like you
were just a baby you should remember
what this was like but she instantly you
know wants to establish herself as a big
girl so she wants to play with someone's
older or her age and maybe there's a
little baby trying to get in and I can
see her like exclude her and of course I
say you know baby don't exclude you know
let her play and then I was thinking
about it I was like that's so funny CU
all grown-ups are doing is excluding
first class comedian list you're invited
on the podcast who didn't I invite on
the podcast that's all we do that's how
we make meaning life is just like what
car do you have who's your wife like
this is my wife you can't have her it's
all excluding do you know what I'm
saying so we teach kids don't exclude as
if that's preparing them for the world
in any way you should I'm not saying you
shouldn't but then I'm like and then
baby when you're 18 I'll teach you how
to exclude real good here's how we
exclude you got to work hard so you can
fly premium economy that's the first
exclusion you know what I'm saying and
then we got the real fancy pants that
they're in the private jet we all admire
them because they're excluding the most
the the billionaires that's they're
exclusion Masters and they're the heroes
of our country cut to us on the
playground going like let everyone play
why don't we do that no one's letting
everyone play no one does that make
sense yeah man that's not you're not in
first class you're in business elect
first class exactly you're not a diamond
like the Delta when you're in line to
board a plane and I let's say I am in
first class and you're flying Delta they
announce 15 groups that board before
first class I know this so I'm I can
relax but I watch the other people and
they're going I'm group one I'm group
one I'm like man on Delta Group one is
group seven you're about to watch
parents with children people who need
assistance then you're going to watch
the military then you're going to watch
the uh 1K members then you're going to
watch the Diamond Elite member then then
they'll get to you and it's like the
plane's half full it's like sorry dude
like eat [__] you
lose I remember they were like they were
mentioning um con key concierge key is
another one and and um and I remember
asked this this old man like this old
like he like a guy that just travels all
day he had that face you know like he
could be a pilot with that face he got
pilot face yeah man and he was old and
then he goes I asked him what's coner
key and I forgot his comment but he said
something like if you don't know you're
not going to you're not on it or
something like that whatever if you have
to ask you'll never know so you have to
ask whatever right and I looked at him
and I said well you're not on it so I
want to know maybe you
know right you don't you're not in it
you're not in it you had to ask so you
don't know why are you see this is
exactly my point the people they could
have just been like I don't know either
or a I just want to know I should have
just asked them listen you [__]
how many miles do it take to be that
[__] I don't know what it is
but he's buying into the idea that it's
called concierge key that's just two
words that mean you fly way too much it
should be the so sorry you never see
your family group man I I flew on I
think it was United I was first class on
United and the guy that was sitting next
to me he was uh I don't know he was
lying or something he said he was James
Franco's
bodyguard and he's like a big bodyguard
and he was um I don't know what he was
he was trying to get on the plane by
saying I'm James Franco's he was on the
plane already in Me With Me In First
Class telling you but he's telling me
that he's like he has like over millions
of miles from traveling with James
Franco and traveling with all the people
that he protects he said
that when he gets on a plane he's
greeted and I saw him being greeted by
by a a real well-dressed flight
attendant like not the ones that are in
a plane M this little she look like a
model and she said welcome Mr
Lopez
Gonzalez big old Mexican dude welcome
welcome and she gave him a bottle of
water on the way in yeah and then got
human yeah when he got in there the guy
the guy greeted him like this and then
he sat down on the way out there was a
lady waiting for him and told him um
your your um baggage claim is this she
was explaining everything to right you
get human like it's not AI but it's a
human acting like they're in AI just for
you I was on a we were we I FW Chicago
with him and we had a
layover and he took me to the the the
lounge you know of United and it was a
big Lounge man there was a place to nap
and masturbate you want to be there I've
masturbated there yeah there was a
showers there was
food yeah the free food I see a lot of
people in those first class lounges
trying like they can't handle that it's
free so you the real frequent Travelers
are just sitting they're just sitting
they're checking their phone they're
making sure they but the people that are
there for the first time they're like
getting nine desserts you know what I'm
saying like me putting them in your bag
yeah yeah of course it's like my parents
once you had a certain age you put the
rolls in your purse my parents are fine
financially they're fine Bread Butter
everything's going in the purse and I'm
looking at them and I'm like when does
this happen like something just clicks
in your brain and you're like I'm old
the bread's coming I think what their
parents grew up in a depression that's
what I agree but like they didn't isn't
it funny you inherit what they did the
fear I just uh Neil Brennan sent me this
talk and they were like try a
psychologist was saying try to imagine
what were your parents afraid of what
were they struggling with and how did
that get handed over to you like how are
you irrationally worried about what your
parents were worried about even though
maybe and very likely you shouldn't be
but you just get it like it's crazy like
your jeans carry a memory have I told
this story on the Pod I read this book I
forget what it was but there was this
dude who couldn't sleep because he was
18 years old and every night at 3:00
a.m. he woke up and he and he couldn't
go back to sleep so he had insomnia
nothing was helping they give him
ambient didn't matter 3:00 a.m. he
always woke up it might have been 1:00
a.m. 3:00 a.m. is kind of like a magic
witching hour I just met in the middle
of the night finally goes to a therapist
they start unpacking his family he's
like I don't care about you tell me
about everything you know about your
family they uncover that his uncle died
when he was 18 the same age as this kid
his car broke down in the in a snowstorm
and he had to crawl they found his body
dead at 1:00 a.m. at the time he kept
waking up crawling away from the truck
so they think then you know his that
memory is in the gene whatever gets
passed through to him somehow it sounds
like magic but they start working on
that and as soon as they uncovered that
he stopped doing it he was able to sleep
because he was waking up and going don't
fall asleep don't fall asleep if I fall
asleep I'll die which was the fear of
his dead uncle that got like into the
mix and handed down so I've been doing
that I'm like my parents were worried
about money growing up like there was a
lot of tension about money I was like oh
yeah I got that I got that and then I'm
like now I'm like what the what the [__]
else do I have like my mom is a refugee
from World War II she left Lithuanian
when was seven cuz the Nazis were there
and I'm like [__] you know what I mean
I'm like no that that's in me somewhere
and I have like a resting sort of like
is anything coming to get me kind of
feeling and I'm like I wonder how much
of that you inherit from your
folks I know right like like my growing
up my my dad and my mom they fear
the what's that which is a boogeyman oh
no don't say it two more times they
always tell me this go to
sleep go to sleep or the boogy man G to
take you I don't like this or um or U
make sure you cover up your your feet
because um the devil might come and just
gr snatch your feet so you have to wear
shoes the devil see shes you cover up
your feet with your blanket he's like
I'm not lifting a blanket I'm the devil
I got a lot of souls to torture I can't
be lifting up blankets grabbing feet if
your feet are exposed I grab him you
know there's kind of like a wisdom to
that it's probably like I was just in
Mexico I got bit by a scorpion should
have had the covers on you know what I'm
saying it was in bed pull the covers up
so there is a wisdom to that and then it
becomes like a story about the devil CU
that's more compelling I guess yeah the
devil and um I don't go to I don't go to
church that much but I was born Catholic
and um I don't practice Catholicism like
I used to before but it still stuck in
my head and the fear like like like
during like a Passover during Lent yeah
and I'm hanging out somewhere somewhere
and I and I'm vegan but I see somebody
eating like pork or meat on on um Good
Friday yeah I said oh something bad
going to happen to that [__]
yeah dude I used to feel he's cursed
when I was a teenager and I was hornier
than anybody's ever been and it was
Easter Sunday and all I wanted to do was
jerk off I was like I can't it's Easter
and of course I still would I just feel
so bad about it you would give up
masturbating for Lent no it just I
didn't want to jerk off on a holy day oh
yeah which is ridiculous but it's
there's almost like a not a sexual
fetish but there's a fetish to it it's
like I'm I'm being naughty you know what
I mean it feels kind of let's put it
this way you're paranoid or you're
afraid but at least you're not bored
it's kind of fun to be like don't do
that don't do that like that's bad luck
black cat crosses your path a slice of
bread lands butter down whatever it is
it's fun to be like cuz you feel so
alive you know what I'm saying I never
heard of that one the a slice of bread
falls down butter down they say the
devil's near I forget what what
tradition that's from but if you have a
buttered slice of toast and falls and it
lands butter down that means the devil's
near and I'm like or it just means your
breakfast is ruined I don't know why are
we bringing a demon into this my dad
will whip you with a BT if you drop that
bed with butter on the bottom he'd be
mad whip you with a bounce were you was
that the situation yeah I'm so sorry my
dad was one of those people that um he
he'll whip with a bout it's [__] upir
[__] up it's [__] up I guess he
would Whi too I guess but he ended he
handed he handed on a tradition no yeah
well hurt people hurt people you've
heard that right I think that's where
does that's one of Father Greg's biggest
points to me is it's like don't you see
this is being handed down there are no
evil people there's mentally unwell
people and mental I'm working on a joke
about this where I'm like I think it's
so funny that we think God is mad at us
let's say I cheat on my wife so God's
mad at me right I'm bad I did the wrong
thing but then I go out for a drink with
you not a drink I don't drink either but
we go out and we have dinner and I tell
you that some flaw something that
happened in my childhood that made me
afraid of closeness closeness actually
means death if I'm too close to somebody
I'm in danger cuz maybe I had a
manipulative mother or maybe I had
whatever it was so of course this
pattern was established if I get too
close I'll self-sabotage I'll cheat on
my wife now we're having dinner you
understand you forgive me you're my
homie you forgive me you love me but God
is mad at me like that is that is like
the most perverse way to look at the
universe that you Felipe Esparza Last
Comic Standing winner can understand my
predicament over a meal and your heart
can be softened but we have this idea of
a God that goes like yeah but you [__]
somebody else like but no listen to what
like you just did it with your dad your
dad did this [__] up thing to you that
[__] up thing happened to your dad
that's the softening of compassion and
understanding I don't know if it's the
sufis but there's a phrase an all
knowing god is an all forgiving God but
we don't even want that we want heads to
roll want people to get [__] up and
build up walls and destroy our enemies
and stuff and I'm like have the the
punch line is I go so you my my friend
Felipe will forgive me but God won't I'm
like have a God that's better than your
friend Felipe right but we don't we have
like a scary scary God murdering angry
he's keeping a list he wants you to
believe in him that's a trip too what
kind of God cares if you believe in him
I mean has anyone stopped to ask that
question like if you made a simulation
like you programmed a f F reality and
you filled it with people and the people
didn't believe in you as a programmer
why would you why would you give a [__]
wouldn't you be impressed you're like I
made such a good program they don't even
know I exist they'd be like I'm I'm dope
I made an atheist you'd be amazed why
would you be mad at something you made
for not knowing you existed like if that
if that was the game God was playing
then it he would do dumb stuff like open
the clouds and go like don't forget I'm
real if that's what really gets him off
is being believed in
be more believable you know what I'm
saying I know like when people say like
I'm atheist or whatever or like like me
I don't go to church no more yeah you
don't care about God I want you to throw
that Bible to trash whoa whoa
whoa I go that part it's Superstition
yeah yeah no I think about that all the
time you let's take like a really
hardcore materialist which is a fancy
word for someone who doesn't believe in
anything and I'm like
will you go in a room and throw 50
Bibles in a bonfire some people might
okay will you go in the most haunted
house the most consistent like The
Comedy Store is haunted go in The Comedy
Store spend the night there we'll give
you the names of the ghosts that are
supposed to be there and just insult
them all night alone just do that will
you do that or will you like will you
let a witch doctor throw bones in the
fire and take a garment of your clothes
and put goat blood on it and look you in
the eye and be like I
I believe in that but that's what I'm
like let's put it to the test you don't
think curses are real let's get this
[__] freaky you know bone neckl let's
do the whole thing for a million dollars
will you let this dude because here's
the trip dude we're putting spells on
each other all day every day in fact I'm
trying to put a spell on you right now
I'm trying to send you love I'm trying
to say you're welcome you're good that
matters the rest of your day the and
therefore the rest of your life will be
different because you talk to me today
and I talk to you I used to think it was
dumb to say hey have a good weekend what
control do I have over your weekend a
lot of [__] control you know what I'm
saying you text me I reply back let's
meet for coffee and we do your whole
life is different because we went for
that coffee I know we know this it
sounds like we're stoned but it's like
it brings such an urgency to every smile
to every stranger or every scowl you're
rude to the TSA you just you just put a
curse on that person I'm not saying you
curse them in fact that could lead to a
good thing cuz I'm an [__] to you you
see that now someone's kind so we don't
know what's for good or what's for evil
but everything really really [__]
matters it's crazy I say this all the
time but they did a study where they
people walk down a hall and they're
introduced to certain words and then
they leave they think they're putting
poems together with words but the study
was to see how fast they walk down the
hall when they leave and the group that
got words like slow lethargic they
walked slow the group that got fast
quick rapid they walked fast so like
think about that I say
patience to you that that ripples
throughout you and then you're going to
drive home differently maybe just a
little bit differently because you'll go
what was a patient you know something
this is why I'm trying to listen to
Greg's books all the time because I'm
trying to get that in me cuz somebody
cuts me off I honk at him maybe he goes
home he's pissed off now he goes home
and yells at his kids you know what I'm
saying or maybe I don't honk at him and
he doesn't we we can't control it maybe
if I had honked him he'd be like oh he's
right I'm an [__] I won't yell at my
kid you know what I mean like you don't
know but like you might as well lean
towards the light does that make
sense let's do some
ketamine I'm just kidding I remember
um I was at the bever center with my
friend Ivan and we were hanging around
around I was just walking and there was
like a bunch of um I don't know they
must have
been I don't know wiggers you know
africanamerican please yeah and um and
they were just chilling hanging out and
then we're just walking and they started
speaking to us like what's up Holmes
what's up B you know like like they were
in Father GG's Boy book oh really
talking like that like they're from Mex
like like they were Cho you know that
they were cholo to us and then my friend
started playing around what's up holes
so that white dude and I went like this
man you know these [__] right
now I change the I change everything you
know these [__] he goes no I
[__] these fools all four of them right
[__] all four of these fools and then
that guy said what I said yeah [__] four
all four you guys I'm going come back
with a bat if you guys are still here
I'm going [__] you guys up you just
didn't like that they were talking to us
like that and that way in that manner
knowing that I know they don't speak
that way right so I thought they were
making fun of us I start right away that
they were making fun of us my friend
didn't so um as soon as um I said I said
we went to our cars and I always had
bats in my car back in the day I have
cuz and and and now late if you have a
bat in your car and the police checks
your car they're going to ask you why
you have a bat m and you have got to
have an answer for them yeah but you
have a
bat another bat a
glove a score a score a fake score of
the last game couple caps catch your
mask yeah Tom a sword inside the drunk
they know you're a baseball
player they know you play baseball you
have one CLE in there this is very good
creative intelligence so we took out the
little bats and um we went out there we
chased them out of the Center they were
still there yeah they I told them to
leave and they they they they left and
then we went to go to the we went to go
do other stuff for about an hour and a
half and I said it goes go my friend
said what are you doing I got to tray
back to make sure the [__] left
they're not still messing around here
acting stupid bothering people so we
went
in we went in and they were like at
Virgin Records you know or Warehouse
that's how the story is and they were
listening to music on headphones the
listening station yes and then my
friends saw one of the guys and he
tapped the window with a bat oh God and
he go get out of and then they both ran
and I think they call the cops and
security so they were fake all along oh
God what made you think of that story I
don't know why about changing People
yeah that's another way to change the
rest of their lives was different that's
so funny because okay so that seems like
a pair terrible there's two dudes two
actually latinx people you and your your
friend you both saw the same thing he
took it as these guys are trying to
connect you took it as they're making
fun of me that's one of the most
interesting like screens were looking at
reality did you see the movie The Whale
Brandon
Frasier it's it's the one where he's got
the big fat suit
on no I didn't see it it's it's okay I'm
not even saying big dude right and he's
gay too yeah he's big and gay a gay
whale he's a gay whale hunt back did you
know dork means whale dick yes in in
London right I didn't know that I just
found that out last night what Stoner
Surfer scientist marine biologist was
like that's not a dick that's a dork
dude look at that thing like he called
it a dork it's so close to Dick yeah
when I saw that when I read about the
movie the whale and I saw that that that
it was that he was also obese and um he
was gay it just made me too sad you know
you didn't want to watch it I remember
feeling that way cuz I know my brother
was gay growing up and he had a hard
time you know and oh yeah and I didn't
want to watch I don't want to go through
that it's not like that oh no okay no he
doesn't even leave the house so
nothing's happening in terms your
brother was harassed and stuff no yeah
yeah that sucks see this is what I was
trying to get at this sounds like
tension you joked about being tense
about the spelling be got a gay brother
who's being harassed
you're getting beaten with a belt come
on Felipe open up man this is your time
this is your time do your
share help people that's funny when I
joke about it I try to like make draw
light my brother likes all my jokes by
the way I make light and no no he was
not gay it's not his fault you know he
was sucked into it you
know my brother and and his partner when
they hear when they would hear that joke
they would just go like this oh no
so he's out now it it work out my
brother out man he was he was out um he
was yeah he was out since I guess when
we were teenagers that's that's Brave I
remember um yeah man it was
tough yeah but he's handsome too yeah
he's not like like handsome like I
remember doing a bit about it in my
first bit cuz my brother's gay man he's
goodlooking he can have any man he wants
want he wants a
woman that's like having Superman
powers but you wake up every morning you
tell yourself I'm not going to rescue no
one cuz he's got help
sorry you mean the falling people are
women yeah help and I remember my
brother was dating somebody that was not
good-looking and I was try to talk to
him like a brother you know like a like
a guy talking to one of his best buddies
like you bro
you could do
better I'm only saying this cuz that's
the kind of you know cuz I'm an ugly guy
that's something I will pick
up but bro you could do better challenge
yourself you're not applying
yourself and um I remember like hanging
out with my brother and then hot chicks
would look at him and all women oh he
he's he's so hot and I'm but they [__]
blocking yeah he's gay though he's gay
what a
waste and I said I'm not gay what a
shame you're trying to scoop in scoop
yeah well that's like Ricky Martin I
mean women love gay men Ricky Martin is
gay yeah dude wow I didn't know that you
were today days old I didn't know that I
thought he was one of those people that
was never going to share his sexuality
with people is that out I'm checking
that's got to be out that's out really
yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah Enrique glaus is
straight the the comedian the no not
Enrique the the the Gabriel
glaus Gabriel the movie the world was
about
him I I didn't laugh at
that no I'm talking about Enrique
glaes no way he's no he's straight oh
he's straight okay I'm saying he's
straight his dad was like Enrique glacia
right or Julio Julio glacia
all the girls i' before yeah he a real
yeah that was a is Right humid in he
sang with um Willie Nelson yeah that's
right that's right so
okay they take control that's Enrique
yeah yeah take care the same Mo Mama Mia
yeah they got the same he got his Mo
removed I know and I bought it off
eBay Grand switches it cost me 500 PES
[Laughter]
it's like people that buy Napoleon's
dick they buy it somebody said the
surgeon cut Napoleon's dick off when
they were doing his aop third leg or
what yeah I don't think it was very big
sorry nle sorry nle sad um I was doing a
cruise ship with bur crer okay the it
was called um ber Crasher at se yeah
with a bunch of other comedians I met
like Mark Norman
and yeah hey man isn't what happened
yesterday was
out that's
it that's so it w he's great he's great
awesome there was a I was a judge of a
speedo contest with Miss Pat and a big
Jake oerson and a th Mark Norman
too and ber Crasher was sober October
sober everything but when he got to that
ship he started he he took his first
drink drink and after that he just
started drinking through the whole
ship and it was a speedo contest that
turned into the smallest man
contest immedately let's see the
smallest wiener the smallest wiener oh
wow so then it was like show your [__]
and this guy took out his
penis and it was small bro it was like
stop bro it
was like the the the no no that that
right there man that's a micro yeah and
that came in second I like that you
look that came in second place by the
way B crer said can anybody beat this
I'll give you five
grand and B creser sure was already off
you know it was on yeah right his wife
already getting the check ready you
know and I was in the back I was that a
contestant still for the regular Speedo
contest yeah and I
said you want to get on this man and
there was this woman and she was rubbing
her husband's shoulders Ryan you got
this shut the [__] I don't know his name
it could have been Austin it was a white
name shut Montgomery she was she knew
she knew come on sweetie you got this
you got this calm down got this Comm is
go in the pool not get hard you got this
get in the cold pool and show it did he
do it man he put it he put it took it
off and flashed it right in front of his
Pat oh my God and she said that if you
in order to go down on it first you got
to open it like a clitteris and open it
and Sh and shape
it bro
he and this guy his his um he his
tattoos stop in the back his all his
tattoos did not match that penis the
penis energy cuz he had tanks and
American Eagle a big the goody year
blimp is on his chest yeah fireworks
bro oh
America the Beautiful those type of
tattoos you know like I'm not going to
wear a
mask you know but U yeah maybe I should
not say that I'm not going to wear a
mask part but yeah it was br
American no did he and he got it he won
the but then B said you guys got to
split it so he got 2500 with the other
guy cuz they were so
similars but that guy won though he
really won but look if your wife clearly
you don't want to do it and BT's like
you're get five grand and you go up and
do the scariest thing you've ever done
in your life which is let your worst
dream come true and let everyone laugh
Miss Pat is going to roast your your
micro penis you should get five grand
then big J roasted him too cuz he had
like this big scar I guess from or H
from his past I guess yeah and then Jay
say something like Jake say something
like I wonder what how smaller it was
before the axe
wound oh God man and this is not like we
were like only like 3 hours into the
trip and going to be on the boat the
rest of the time I could still I was
still waving at Cubans at um laara
restaurant in Miami
bro like that's how close we were to the
to the to the
shore like you're not even in
international waters not even
International this good old American fun
as the tattoos would appreciate
yes then we still had like four more
days of travel wow if you open with a
micro penis competition where do you go
from there what's day four belly flop
content with no clothes on okay I don't
like that I'm not doing that this sounds
a little bit like there's that episode
of The Simpsons where Mr Burns hires
Homer to just humiliate himself he just
gives him money I'm like this sounds a
lot like that it's like just go hurt
yourself it was wild man it was a guy
that was at the at the speedo contest
who was wearing that um Bull rock
bathing suit oh sure oh he came prepared
so it was announced ahead of time this
would be happening yeah it was a bathing
it was a bikini contest like a speedo
contest but then later on that night
we're having like the this crazy karaoke
party where everybody's singing it was
totally fun it a lot of
fun um this guy was but was Buzz and he
was
singing can you take me
higher to to the BL and he's killing it
but then I see the guy from the speedo
contest cheering him on wearing the same
speed from the morning bro so now we're
like 12 hours in he's still wearing the
same Speedo and I'm bored you know I'm
not drinking I'm trying to find stains
on it you know
maybe my wife had Point Ah that's the
guy who didn't even win he kept it on
I don't like this I don't like this so
you're sober and you're a vegan and
you're going on booze cruises how's that
well I lost a lot of weight on that [__]
Bro not eating yeah right I don't think
they had like a good V not like not that
many V vegan options so when we got to
the
Bahamas my wife and I we ran to a Burger
King cuz I know they have veggie patties
there there you
go why did you become a vegan I was
doing the Atkins diet yeah back in the
day when when I was tring with another
comic we were all doing it yeah a bunch
of
comics but I was doing it the wrong way
I was only eating cheese and beef all
day no salads also no water oh God and
no just Diet Cokes oh no so Diet Coke um
just patties and cheese bro and I was
constipated for 5 days I don't like this
yeah that's about right yeah man I must
have ripped my co in when I finally went
to the bathroom that's what they mean by
have it your way
yes I need it came out with no secret
sauce oh God it was bad man
and I said forget this no more meat I
blame it on meat so and so fi there's no
I stopped eating be beef and I started
eating cheese for two weeks straight I
was just eating whatever that whatever
is not beef whatever is in cheese like
no milk either just rice
and beans and vegetables yeah so I just
kept eating that and I went to the
restroom and I pooped and it was black
like old stuff and I had to go look to
make sure I wasn't dying you know yeah
and it was like a big piece of it looked
like li like liver it was black and I I
Googled it right away man what the
[__] going on and then that was all my
toxin leaving yeah yeah I didn't know
that you had you had a lot of bad stuff
going on and also during my um during
the time when I had when I was
constipated I had a hemorrhoid for the
first time I never had one in my life
and people ask me I was like what do it
feel like it feels
like you're sleeping and you're being
raped by a a ghost that used to be a
prison inmate every
night like every night that ghost puts
down your trousers
and has it his way has it your way yeah
there you go and God the next day man
wearing the wearing the Burger King hat
too oh God cuz it's his birthday yeah
every day the next day I was just so
sore man I felt like I was sodomized I F
I was
attacked and I didn't know what's going
on so I kept it quietly you know now who
you going to tell this to yeah like you
can't tell that to another comic or
friend of your a bro your ass bro why
you telling me this go talk to a doctor
this is the first you're the first ass
vegan I've ever met it was all but you
know what I me
man so then after then my wife she was
raised vegan in Ohio with her mother in
Ohio wow I just say that cuz when I
think of the Heartland I'm like that's
so much know man how did how did a woman
raise three kids vegan in Ohio wow it's
commitment so she had something
something to do with it you became vegan
after she she was vegetarian she was
vegan vegetarian when I met her but me
I'm all bad like I told I know you're
vegan I know you're vegan and you grew
up eating not eating meat but this is La
man you never had a a spicy chicken
sandwich on Jack inut box at 2 in the
morning with jalapeno poppers on the
side and grilled and cheese sticks on
top of your hood yes and then she said
nah so then I got into eating um chicken
from Jack inut box oh you turned her
yeah but she was already eating it but
not at all I never see and not like real
good stuff like Jack in the Box yeah
Jack In The Crack Jack In The Crack Man
2 in the morning number
five but you're sober what are you doing
at Jack In The Box at 5: in the morning
but that was back then man oh you
weren't sober yet no I was just no I I
wasn't drinking but um I was doing a lot
of late shows hanging out L yeah and
Jack in the Box is always open well you
mentioned that what did you get into in
the drugs crack I love crack you love
crack how did how did that come about
who gave you crack my
neighbor my brother had just been shot
like he was shot by the police the same
brother we were talking about yeah oh no
no another brother my brother that
brother my other brother n gay he's
good-looking um my brother was shot by
the police
what was he doing what what happened oh
being bad he was being bad I didn't mean
to imply that he was he deserved to be
shot but what happened shot oh no no no
no no I mean what's happening what was
going on funny man like when people like
I know like black lives matter right and
you know black people get shot
and they they protest police reform and
Mexican people we get shot too you know
like Cubans Puerto Ricans Dominicans and
newor New
York Latinos we get shot too you know
but at the end of the day man you know
we want to protest and get mad but we
don't want to get
involved like at the end of the day we
we we we we we we we think bu go I got
to be at work tomorrow morning I work
with a lot of white people you know it's
a hassle it's a hassle you know talking
hassle you're the first ass vegan I've
met and the first hassle non-activist
like I also when Latinos get shot we try
to find out what really happened you
know the whole story not the social
media story then we find out the cop was
act a Mexican too so he shot another
Mexican and it kind of makes it all
right you know he got shot by our own
people you know it rasa again rasa homie
no like my brother was shot
like nobody no one came up to us said
you got to sue the cops you got to get
you got to come down in a city right but
isn't that just institu like you've been
pushed down so hard it's not even an
option isn't that a
tragedy my my mom were they were like my
mom was afraid that the cops were going
to come to our house and start
questioning us and then everybody going
to see the cops in our house and bring
shame to our house right cuz I grew up
in a neighborhood like the cops go to
your
house it's over like you guys are
losers are you're loser like why is the
cop at your house like you're going to
lose your immigrant status now you can't
get a green card now well it's crazy I
don't know if did you watch the
telemarketer thing on Max I loved it
wasn't it good but remember they
targeted immigrants cuz they would call
and say will you donate and you get the
sticker and you have a lot of illegals
that are donating their money to get a
sticker that doesn't mean [__] because
people are exploiting the fear of of
being an illegal immigrant you know what
I'm saying so there's something similar
going on here it's like the oppression
continues because there's this fear of
like getting getting deported right M
but just because you came into the
country that way doesn't mean I don't
have to tell you this it's like that's
still [__] sucks but somebody like
that like who is proud to live in
America and he's an immigrant and he's
going to work every day and you tell him
hey man you want to support the cops see
of course it's part of it's part of my
neighborhood right how we're going to
start the sticker just put in the back
of your station wagon sure how much 20
let me get two yeah and then it makes
them feel like it's toing us to make it
feel we're more American get no I get it
that's what I mean it's it's
exploiting uh you want to belong you
want to show that you're there I get it
but I come from a uh but I come from a
neighborhood where for us you know what
911 happened a lot of people in my
neighborhood had go USA bumper stickers
yeah USA number one it made me think of
the American flags but yeah they they
rather put the go USA but not pay for
their tags yeah right that their tags
might be expired right right but go
America right right the tag is another
kind of donation to the government
it is another way to support the police
I remember when my tag were expired my
neighbor my landlord who was paying
ran anyway that fool said he saw my tag
with expired yeah and he goes if you
want if you want one I got an extra one
I'll s it to you he said for how much 25
bucks
wow anyway so he wanted to sell me a an
extra
tag to yeah yeah yeah the one for yeah
and did hell no oh hell no man I'm me I
rather drive with expired tags than fake
tags yeah right that's crazy that's
crazy I drove to Las Vegas one
time with to do a show cuz I need the
money of course I need the money and
um I I just said yes I'll do it and not
not knowing that I have a bad car and
all that and I said yes I'll do it I
said I'll do it and man like you know
people talk about like oh man this guy
he clim Mount Everest you know he climb
Mount Everest this guy um he does
Jiu-Jitsu cuz his nose broken you know
this guy goes into this ice chamber like
Joe Rogan and gets all Frozen n man you
want a real Challenge Drive to to Las
Vegas to do a gig for $200 in a bad car
with a bad car with expired tags and no
driver license and child support coming
after you
stop that's your Iron Man challenge
that's my Iron Man holes yeah yeah yeah
yeah did you make it I made it man where
are you at now I mean the second gig
that's second time they Char they they
they G they boo me I said I'll take the
bus I took a gound bus
yeah no that that might be better the
gas to get to LA from LA to Vegas has
got to be at least 100 bucks yeah I lost
a lot of money in that gig I hate the
story I want I want more I want more I
lost man what time I I did the math I
made like
$35 I can't you could have made more
selling your fake tags I could have made
home more money staying at
home pardon the interruption weirdos
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at AR armra you guys know I am
obsessed with ways to strengthen my
immunity my gut health as well as my
fitness endurance and my metabolism as
well as my hair and my Skin's Radiance
and I recently discovered one product
that does all of that and it couldn't be
easier to incorporate into my life
talking about armra colostrum colostrum
is one of those things that keeps coming
up in conversation with my friends what
is it colostrum is the First Nutrition
we receive in life and contains all of
the essential nutrients our bodies need
to thrive I'm talking about reactivating
hair growth and glowing skin by reducing
inflammation and puffiness in your face
and neck as well as stimulating stem
cells to produce collagen and increase
elasticity talking about igniting your
metabolism and fortifying gut health so
you feel less bloated and lighter in
general while replenishing your
microbiome stabilizing blood sugar and
accelerating fat burning as well as
fueling your Fitness performance and
your recovery Arma colostrum is a
proprietary concentrate of Bine
colostrum that harnesses over 400 living
bioactive nutrients that rebuild the
barriers of your body and fuel cellular
health for a host of research backed
health benefits it's wholly natural
sustainable and was developed with the
highest Integrity talking about
grass-fed in the United States and they
guarantee the highest potency and
bioavailability of any colostrum on the
market for results that you actually see
and feel and I can attest to that I add
it to my smoothie you don't even notice
but you notice the feeling meaning you
don't notice it in the Smoothie but the
the results are palpable so we've worked
out a special offer for weirdos receive
15% off your first order go to tr
ara.com weird or enter weird to get 15%
off your first order that's
try a RM
a.com weird we also brought To Us by our
friends of course I'm wearing them you
tues the perfect jean guys I love the
perfect Jean in a nutshell it's a
stretchy Jean that no one needs to know
meaning it looks as good as any designer
Jean that I've paid way too much for
I've worn it to movie premieres I've
worn it on late night I never don't wear
them but the secret is 2% Spandex and
2.5% rayon for extra Comfort meaning
they're as comfortable as pajama pants
in fact I have slept in them they are
that comfortable they're also the best
looking I love the dyes I love the
colors they have a new khaki D that I
really really love I'm wearing this uh
very dark sort of midnight blue one
which goes with everything they're also
incredibly incredibly wellmade I never
have to replace them they don't tear
they don't rip things don't pop off they
are awesome High and maximum durable and
they spare your nuts cuz they give you
that stretch you need for that comfort
in your man zone so your nuts ain't
crushed whether you're working with a
lemon or a lentil A three leaf clover a
big old hunk and eggplant the perfect
Jean has you covered I absolutely love
them they also have incredible t-shirts
just check them out it's a great company
and a great product and everything they
make is so so comfortable and looks
incredible the perfect Jean .nyc that's
www.the perfect
jan. NC did I say that the perfect gene.
NC use code weirdo for 20% off at
checkout that's a great discount weirdo
at checkout for 20% off all right back
to
Felipe okay that's that brings us now
you won Last Comic Standing you're
wearing a a tracksuit with matching
Adidas where are you at now now are you
a little more comfortable than you've
been in your life yes I'm I'm very I'm
more comfortable now um I signed with um
Judy BR Judy marel Judy bra marmel okay
leev sure and um I'm with um UTA and
they're working yet yes well how's your
life changed and and in what ways did it
not change man when I won Last Comic
Standing
$250,000 my son's mom f for child
support the next day she was watching
yeah she became the last baby mama
standing
she she ended up I had two kids from her
so they're all grown so she got like a
fat chick you know sure and and all the
kids were so she won she won she became
the last baby mama standing how much how
much of it I thinking like got over
$100,000 cuz that's got to be most of
what you got yeah minus taxes plus taxes
rep and um you made $35 again $35 man
but you know what I when I want last com
standing I didn't know how much I didn't
know that I had debts and unpaid tickets
all came at once yeah like I remember
when I was living by myself in um allean
Valley frog town I used to live next to
um this actor named Emilio Rivera from
Sons of
Anarchy
um forgot my point now you didn't know
you got all your debts came at the same
time your tickets yes so I moved by
myself to a little a place this small
the size of the studio the size of this
like the if you cut it up my kitchen was
like this hallway and the the rest of
the bedroom it was this
small and um I bought a uh I bought
everything on credit for Montgomery Ward
that's how long it was or I bought a
washing I bought a oven a
refrigerator then I thought I didn't
have money to pay for all that stuff so
I never paid them I know that the
company don't even exist anymore somehow
somebody loser bought that debt years
ago and not ready to collect it oh my
God and then my friend this is after you
won then this defunct company guy shows
up looking for it yes and then my friend
who when when I used to have a car I
remember that he got into a car accident
and they told the car and the tow truck
tow truck place they wanted money for
having my car there all all those years
that I never picked it up wow I didn't
even know that that car thought it was
just keep it yeah yeah yeah so thr up
yeah up
$35 at the end of the day I I was debt
free I didn't owe anybody I didn't owe
child support I didn't ow anybody oh and
I donated money to the um homeboy
industry when I was on Last Comic
Standing they were asking all the comics
if you win what are you going to do with
that money this person said I'm buy a
car I'm buy a
house I said
um I'm going to get donate some of my
money to Father great Boo and homeboy
industry yeah cuz if if it wasn't for
them I wouldn't be here today and at the
same time father Greg Bo was close to
losing everything cuz the donation were
not coming in so me saying that on
television was like a commercial for him
yeah so everyone started donating oh
that's awesome so I've donated over like
a lot of money like I donated 10 grand
15 grand wow of my winnings and I've
donated like close to that every year
wow good for you man well here we are
again I hope people donate whenever
whenever I can park in the neighborhood
they still take my car
n you know when I want last come and
standing I had a a homeboy that I grew
up with that helped me terrorize
somebody back in the days and he want to
get paid for that now even this they're
coming and invoicing you did he give you
a print out yeah remember that one time
I helped you beat up this guy that that
jumped you I want say G for that wow he
even had a he wrote it out he did not
write it out that would be great with a
bunch of dots
$10,000 so the money go went away fast
good for you for still donating to
homeboy after you found out so much of
it wasn't coming to you I remember like
when I was last comment standing a lot
of people were saying oh this guy can't
even talk right he stutters you know he
talks weird and then like all right I'll
get back at you guys I donated money to
this Peach impairment school
too you
did I sent him a big F fat check
check I used still have like a speech
impairment growing up but um when you're
growing up in a bad neighborhood and
your mom's you know they don't know
about stuff like that they just beat you
to you talk right wow talk right that's
what my favorite episode of um of um
Bugs Bunny is Porky Pig yeah sure when
he was in a cuz in in the Army it's a
army episode and they tell him to write
your name on the wall and he start
writing a bunch of P's all over the
chalkboard he even stutters when he
writes oh noi my dad would make fun of
me and say I talk like a like a machine
gun
wow yeah how'd that go
away I'm just talking I mean remember
one time um I met this comedian and they
was telling me that um I us to talk like
you bro what my my father no my mother
or I don't know his uncle or somebody he
got me and he he shoved a bunch of
toilet paper in my mouth and made me
talk like that all day this is not the
medical approved strategy so I'm
thinking but I didn't think about it
that they were abusing this kid growing
up right yeah and now he's giving
horrible advice
now so people trying to help um I would
put a and then I would put a bunch of um
paper towels on my cheeks so I could be
like the like Robert um Dair what's his
name Mar Brando and The Godfather yeah
you come here in the day of my daughter
kinger you know so I started like
pretending to talk my God you did it you
tried it I tried it I thought it was
stupid for a while but did it work
no and then my my ex-manager she she
took me to a like a speech Place yeah
and then she was she was telling me like
I don't know she was attracted to me or
something she goes I love your accent
you shouldn't even take this class I
don't know why your manager's paying for
this he goes people need to hear that
voice oh nice and that's how you met
your wife and she bought you that
tracksuit yeah she did man yes she she
did
so then most of the money went away do
you want another one no I'm good you
sure yeah I'm good do you feel it I
don't know if I feel it or not it's hard
to know sometimes does it make you hyper
no cuz it calms you down and it picks
you up I love it it's hard sometimes
people it builds it builds now that
after you won did that more money came
in there like more success did it lead
to more success or were you were a
little disappointed yeah it led to more
success I I thought like I went on tour
with the last Last Comic Standing
comedian 85 City Tour isn't that in the
contract yeah but don't they they take a
pretty big bite of that yeah yeah we're
not making a lot of money well I was
making more money than the other Comics
so I was happy right it was more money I
would make it any anywhere so right and
I got to meet I got to travel to places
I only heard in music but did you have
the problem that people that do Last
Comic had where it's like I just did all
my material on TV oh no man I had a lot
of material oh really cuz I started
doing standup comedy like a '94 so you
had all this stuff yeah I've just talked
to some guys that were like I won and
now I have to do yeah man I will see Roy
Woods Jr and um the other comedians
they're like grinding man writing jokes
yeah going back and forth my wife and I
man we were like a comedy team by the
time I I I would do my three minutes my
wife would give me a a list of the next
three J three minutes to do and I would
just do it again if the show would have
went on another 10 weeks I think I would
have had another 3 minutes for each week
wow that's really hard having an opener
and a closer in three minutes is really
hard cuz um I I um I have all my sets
recorded like on on little cassettes and
I have all my sets recorded on my phone
too so you would listen to them I I
listen to him every day every day every
day like I if I did a show I did a show
so
recently two weeks ago in in Rotterdam
Rotterdam amster Holland yeah okay and I
did a show there was like an hour and I
and I went to go listen I listen to it
my whole trip when I was in Europe must
have listen to it like five times what I
have such a hard time listening to
myself I'm really impressed that you
have that discipline I listened to it
because I don't want to write it you
know I don't want to write down I want
to memorize it by listening to it so and
then when I memorize it if I if I come
up with a new tag while I'm listening to
it I write the whole sentence down yeah
then I save it and then I went to go use
it somewhere else wow like when I I went
to go see I I wrote a joke I went to go
see that band the English Beat uhuh they
that song
um other songs are in movies now they're
they've been touring the guy said he was
touring now for 45 years wow the English
be they have that song There's SC mirror
in the bathroom please talk free the
door is open just use your key can you
take me to a restaurant and got glass
tables you can watch yourself while you
are
eating yeah yeah okay I'm skanking yeah
and
um so it was a small venue bro like
small like they were opening up and then
I thought I would joke wild man I'm at
the age now where I could watch all my
bands together has Six
[Laughter]
Flags cuz before it be like this summer
Los Angel Coliseum iron made yeah yeah
but now man included with your ticket of
Six
Flags iron Med hosted by Dean Del
Reay and the Hellraisers you know the
heav metal
podcaster I know Dean know right yeah
and then you could be like you know what
I'm not you going to buy a ticket
I know D D let me open
dog oh my God let me give you a ride
there yeah I'll do it for the ride you
let me in for the ride that so then
after that 85 City Tour things have
continued to grow I mean you're touring
with Bert you're
headlining touring with Edie Griffin too
who with Eddie and I toured with Mike
EPS y these are great guys he took me
along Mike was crazy man he's like a big
child Mike
did these guys give you any good advice
any lines that stuck with you did they
shape you push you how to play a bigger
room whatever it might have been only
from um man Ricky
Smiley I don't know if you know him I
don't know if I know him he's um he's a
he's a legend this guy is so funny like
this guy could
um he could grab this paper this Cube
and and just look and go m mammals and
just him saying that start laughing yeah
yeah just a funny person and uh he's
funny and I never seen
anybody get a standing ovation in
between sets while hosting wow that's
incredible I've never seen that and and
I go wow I go I'm going up first right
and this guy is like I felt like Dewey
Cox in that movie Dewey Cox when um
Alvis Presley just got off yes did you
have to um take it all Mr Presley yes
yes so I'm he he does his set roaring
right everybody knows who he is
obviously and I'm the first comic and
then um he puts up a a local guy a a guy
that's who's local to the area and his
Mike 's friend and that guy destroys too
destroys then he then he does another
five minutes after him then it's my turn
he bring he does this song that I never
heard of cuz I know hip hop but I never
heard this song and I guess this song is
hot was hot back then and man I never oh
my God the whole audience
everybody people the song was killing
the song 7,000 people rose up and wave
like this with him it was that song Bone
Crusher okay or in the club and you
think I'm
my so I go to my car and I take up my
nine and then the the the the the hook
shows up I tell you I would never stop I
would never stop and then dude he has
everybody
going all right man y'all ready for your
next comedian now they have to fade the
song that they're all loving now
interrupting your favorite song Felipe
Esparza
this is a nightmare what you're telling
me is elevating my heart rate like I'm
nervous so I told her I went back to te
I went back to the song I man change my
song After the Show change that [__]
ass song I was going to go up to oh
before you went out yeah I was going to
go something that would have
just I said just go up there and just
put um kiss me put a Cypress
Hill um insan in a membrane yeah there
you go cuz I have long hair yeah there
you go so I could just go up there as
it's pot looking guy that they never
seen before yes and how' it go it went
good it went good man right off the bat
yeah that's awesome cuz they went like
this I want to go then but then they
play the the song but then they stop it
like a regular DJ
stop so then I got to go up there man
and I could feel like like confidence
that I don't have you know yeah you
know it's F like hosting the Golden
Globes bro like yeah I'm not getting
nothing you know nothing I'm going start
blaming people why did my Asian book me
here you know why did my Asian book me
you know we just watched that before you
got here you know tough like I I I I
felt unprepared you know like I was
booked 10 minutes before this 10 minutes
ago not 10 days you know I I felt the
pain you know I felt I feel I feel other
Comics pain yeah that's something a
comedian no matter who you are if you're
telling me a story about somebody
bombing or somebody not having a good
time on stage oh no I know brother Katie
told me did you watch the Globes and
then I watched it and I was watching it
from a very sympathetic place oh me too
you know what I mean I wasn't like I've
never done that I I laughed at the jokes
some of the jokes and I and but I was
also looking around to see why why
what's going on here yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I also didn't think it was that bad
and I'm not just saying that no when the
headline says Joe Koy bombs I'm clicking
it which which is what it is it's
clickbait and I watched the
guy doing his job you know you guys
don't know what bombing is obviously you
don't that's thank you that's it you
don't know what bombing is bombing is
bombing is sweat bombing when you're up
there trying to work that joke out and
then you see your wife or somebody she's
flirting with the last com who
killed
that's bombing and she's still laughing
at his jokes if he was hear your wife
laughing while you're up there
struggling yes if you're bombing you can
hear their tongue it's so dry it's
flopping in this Cavern it's it's the
lonliest emptiest nastiest and he and he
said I didn't write these jokes that's
called a save line save line he's trying
to make you laugh by doing something
you're not supposed to do he's not
actually going a he's [__] right this
guy suck I fired him after this yeah
it's it's it's like old show business
it's like folks I didn't write this I'm
doing my best you know cuz you're out
there I remember I had to do a a a roast
with this comedian very funny comedian
um aah Rodriguez we're doing like a a
host of a wedding party we're going to
roast him and I remember they wrote all
these jokes plus our jokes for the roast
was this filmed it was filmed one time
and Patrice wasn't there was he no but I
know a story about Patrice doing
something like this but not that one but
the the producers of our show was a
producer of The Big J show okay zo zo
Zulan or something like that yeah yeah
Ben Stiller so they [__] uh not Zulan
in the movie that be cool though and the
blue steel production company and I we
reading the jokes I didn't want to like
talk bad say like these trokes are
horrible these Tres are never going to
work right I just looked around the ride
I said how many times am I allowed to
say I didn't write this stuff yeah
that's right and I was joking with the
writer then we all laughed and we threw
everything away and started writing more
jokes yeah but I know that that's coming
from I'm going to make my my my writers
laugh at least I hear that and also I
love that story because if the jokes
aren't
working somebody I forget who told me
this somebody told me that it was Jud
Jud Appel he was like the writers aren't
there to write you a joke they're there
to say something you that makes you
think of a joke you know what I mean
sometimes it's ready to go just perfect
oh thank you I can do this joke but we
did that on crashing all the time and I
used to get frustrated never mad just
like alone in my trailer looking at it
I'm like my feeling would always be like
you go out there and say this say these
words I want you to do it because that
that that was my fear speaking I never
said that to anybody but then I realized
like no it's true they would write this
joke maybe it was in their voice it
would work for them and then I it was
still my job to turn it into my voice
you know what I mean it's not done it's
not Amazon Prime like the joke shows up
they say something it makes you think of
something like I love that story there's
a story on Mr Show where Brian pain
pitched something terrible and it was it
was supposedly so bad everyone laughed
and made fun of him and then Bob
Odenkirk was like no you're a funny guy
let's unpack that like that it doesn't
work now but something about that made
you laugh let's find it and they
reworked it and it turned into one of
their best sketches so that's what I
like about you you're like look we're
all in this together this isn't there
yet let's laugh at it let's let's call
it out I don't want to pretend like this
is ready but then you you build up a
camaraderie and then you fix it yeah
yeah that's right I love that so I oh I
had like nine other things to ask you
and now it's my turn and I just don't
have it I'm just kidding how many times
have you ever almost died died how like
dead oh on stage
I you could tell me a bomb story too cuz
that's on my mind too oh man how'd that
roast go did it go okay what roast the
the wedding party oh it went well yeah I
thought maybe you were leading to a bomb
but it was like drama because we're
we're she's hanging out she's hanging
out with all the Bridesmaids yeah and
trying to get like trying to get inside
stuff of them to get to know them and
then roast them later yeah and I'm get
hanging around with the males right and
then we switch like I go I do I do um I
do um Bachelor at bridesma stuff we get
her feet done with them and we're
talking I'm getting my nails done um aah
Rodriguez she's over there with um the
guys and they're getting
tattoos the night on the on one of the
nights that we're supposed to do the Big
Show the groom is caught with another
woman you stop it no he's caught with
another woman on on a motorcycle wrong
show man that's
cheaters that's what we said man this
show turns into cheaters yeah secretos
the the the tundo version one oh my God
oh my God you ever watch the tundo
cheaters no it is
ridiculous it's amazing it is ridiculous
compared to cheaters bro people go nuts
they go nuts there's this one cheater
episode in tundo it's called secretos
and
secretos they the whole camera crew goes
in in somebody's house and there like
like a cocaine deal going down at the
same time oh my God that's a different
kind of
secretto that is insane they're slapping
the coke bag you know and Coke flying
everywhere and then like then I'm
watching her going wait a minute man
this cam crew Everybody more worried
about her being cheated by this gin yes
instead of all these drugs here and
there's people tie it up only secos
secretos in secretos so they all fake
bro they're all fake actors it was fake
that is really really funny that's the
secret that's the SEC the real secret is
it's not
real what is a bomb that comes to
mind you seem like a guy that even if
it's not going well you're so likable I
can't see you really tanking my bombs
now are more internally than they are
outwardly to people facts and I could go
do a show I do the whole hour but I
could I could I could tell you that and
I told my friends and hope they get it
some they get it what the older comic is
the more they get that one I how was it
it was horrible bro but you did well
yeah but I felt like I was sitting down
watching myself suck yeah yeah yeah dude
you are I didn't I had great shows this
past weekend and Bill bur said this to
me I I was lucky to open for Bill in the
early years of standup and I had a bad
set and he just went like this he was
like you wanted you want this with the
audience and he was like and you you
were this it wasn't like you were bad it
just you never you never a show never
happened you were a guy talking and
that's I can be going getting laughs
hitting all the notes saying all the
things but I have that out of body like
what am I doing oh I hate that feel what
this guy this this guy looks bored or
whatever it is so I'm not I make this
comparison all the time but it's like
having sex it's like have sex with your
wife and she's like where are you you're
still having sex but you can tell you're
not connecting it's the same thing it's
technically stand-up comedy but like
there's a disconnect and when I bomb now
bomb I go off stage and I say I couldn't
find them it's not that they didn't
laugh you know the clothes are closed
the Applause break here everybody had a
good show but I'm like I know what it
could have been it could have been our
honeymoon it could have been like this
magical thing but it was just Jack in
the Box yeah like I don't know what um
improv it is I know one of the Improv is
either Ontario or or
Irvine I stand sometimes I don't know I
don't find the right standing position
in a club like physically physically
like I know it got to be in the middle
but I I I stand over here I feel like I
stand in the wrong spot sometimes yeah
cuz I know that if I'm walking into the
stage I know where to stand but if I'm
walking in to the stage forward yeah I
don't know where to stand I know what
you mean and sometimes something like
that it's a wonder we're not more
superstitious comedians are weird I do
the same things every time but it's
because you're trying to control the
most uncontrollable situation so of
course you're kind of like you know I
have my magic mind my opener goes on
stage I drink my magic mind then I do
this like breath thing and then I do
this and then I have that and then I go
out he he still checking it out
not endorsed by Felipe
Esparza tastes like
DayQuil use said nightquil too the
Sleepy one even more insulting but you
know what I mean like it's stranger that
I'm not like got to take the mic out
with my right hand I got to make sure
for me and one of the reasons I listen
to Father Greg before I go on stage my
Mantra is it's not about the words the
bad shows I have are when I think I have
to say the words right but they might
even think there to hear the jokes and I
feel very strongly about that this
they're actually there to be in a space
with you they want to go somewhere with
you and be in a silly funny light safe
even if it's kind of risky or whatever
but it's still safe it's like a
sleepover or like a good hang it's not
like nobody drives home and goes maybe
they do but I don't really think they're
like the words of that one joke it was
more like Felipe showed up and we he was
like the sailboat and we were the wind
and and we went fast like everybody's
thrilled by that nobody's like he said
those words perfect and we were rowing
right exactly some shows you got to get
out and row it's true I thought like
when I I did my show in um in Rotterdam
yeah at the club hog h u is in rdam and
other other comedians after there was
another show after and it was going to
be in Dutch so my show was in English
and 75 people showed up but I've done
shows in the past where like it's not
sold out I could do a 50 room like no
problem 35 yeah but
like I I I threw in my old my line I
always say when it's not crowded it
killed again what' you say I said man
welcome to the second
show first show
packed we were turning people away I
don't even know why we're doing a second
show right now wow cuz I just have that
cuz I just throw him off with that
that's great that's great yeah when it's
half full three4 full even you're still
kind of like you know they know that's a
great way to address it but I'm in
Rotterdam you know it's always happy
yeah yeah yeah I haven't been there
since yeah nobody goes I'm not a draw in
Holland like you can't feel bad about
that and and then I had um I I had
Latinos at my show in reram WoW there
were um Latinos who live in Holland who
knew I didn't know that and doesn't
matter if um if I set up Mexican over
there cuz I I didn't have to yeah cuz
they they thought I from seram
anyways or some other place do you ever
do full sets in Spanish yes I did a full
set on Netflix oh you did I'm sorry I
should have known that I did um it's
called
um decisions Mal Mal decis
decis decision so it was tough bro cuz
my Spanish is not like it's not it's not
tundo
Spanish it's more like Blood In Blood
Out movies
Spanish like where every other word got
to be
English now you know what I'm talking
about
Mendes hire the radio homes for faor
skis you know so why did you do it did
Netflix want you to do it I told him
I'll do it I'll do it in both languages
and it's oh all right more money okay
yeah so you you taped it twice once in
English once in Spanish is it that's
insane that's crazy the first night I
did two shows in English and the second
night I did two shows in Spanish and
what is the difference performatively
you know Spanish sounds differently you
know the the the way words hit you can't
just translate a a joke from English to
Spanish you got to do something else to
it what do you do there's a play on
words that didn't work either right and
puns don't work yeah and a lot of the
words that I was using in the beginning
when I was practicing didn't exist in
Spanish language like what like breas
what's breas breaks it's a word made up
in California doesn't exist in a regular
no that's not even a word yeah it's it's
called the real word for breaks is fenos
Right f e r n o s right and breas is
just a a Spanglish word made up in LA
right which just we just like you know
white people they don't know how to say
a a Spanish word so they just add a o at
the end of the English word right breos
yeah breos right right so we had as
breas breas it's a feminine word yeah so
we I didn't even know making other words
that were using were made up yeah so
when I went to Mexico to try to through
the full set yeah it was like um it was
a very humbling experience on
experience experience I had I had
comedians that were SP that were
speaking Spanish killing in Spanish yeah
and then it goes oh man but it go over
my notas so so I go over my my my my set
Li WR in Spanish I can't this is like a
nightmare for me and I was like oh
man so my 20% of the Spanish set is
different from the English set because
20% of the jokes did not cross over wow
they didn't work at all and is there a a
a taste like do Spanish speaking
audiences like a certain kind of humor
more than just the English speaking
audience my Spanish was so
American that it's they liked it cuz
they see like this pachuko guy yeah this
guy who grew up in me in United States
who speaks Spanish right and it's
messing up both both languages up cuz
that's what we do you know when you're
we're here to mess up both Lang both
languages so they probably thought that
was funny just on its own yeah because I
have um I have like a very um La accent
and then when I was speaking Spanish so
my and I really wanted my Spanish
version of the special to be for Spanish
speaking Americans who live in a English
language country yeah yeah yeah so if
you're like a Dominican who speaks span
who's learning how to speak English but
you saw my comedy in Spanish you're
going to love it cuz you're going to
relate to it right right right right
you're not going for like native cuz you
want to go like if you want to go like
my friend um caros B
he's the Mexico from Mexico City and all
his humor is totally Spanish he like
he's he's like a very re Renown known
comedian and when he speaks
Spanish I I get it you know I get all
his jokes yeah but I know but I'm never
going to speak that good yeah yeah yeah
you understand and also his English is
better than mine too so yeah [__] this
guy we work together in Montreal oh yeah
I opened up for him in English
no I opened up for him in Spanish okay
and then when I did my English hour in
Montreal he did a he he picked up a
10-minute set and and did it give me an
example so let's take a joke like gangs
aren't all bad at least say carpool say
that how do we say that in Spanish well
I it'll be tough cuz I don't know the
word for carpool in Spanish off the bat
right now P so I was to look it up so I
would say that um see right there man
you're freaking me
carpool is is such an English specific
thing see you have to say like they
share cars yeah
um I don't know oh give me one that you
did translate I will say I will say
like how the gang banging Jer I want to
do it now gangs aren't all bad at least
they carpool that's that was
a
to save the
world he goes and I say gang bang is not
that bad you know they all go inside the
car to save the world on the way to kill
somebody that's nice so I did in
Spanish but does that work they get in
the car to save the world that doesn't
that wouldn't mean they get in the car
to go to save the world no they get in
the cars because they want to protect
the world on the way to kill somebody
yeah but they're prot in the world
because they're getting rid of they're
they're getting rid of a
carbon yeah there you go yeah yeah yeah
they're very green they're very green
know they're getting rid of the carbon
that was left by the
human kind of like gang is C you know he
saved our world is that a thing yeah
gangas Khan he killed so many people
with his army that he depopulated the
world and made the world less carbon wow
because of the other people he murdered
wow during his Wars that's some than
talk about
um cleansing the world yeah getting his
con man he helped he didn't have to grow
no plants very green he just got rid of
people cuz we are kind of the problem
yeah there's got to be a better way
there's extinctionist now I think we
like I read some I don't know if I
didn't read anywhere but my wife said
that she read this article where there's
like this island floating in a in the
ocean somewhere that has all are human
trash just picked up right there the
trash island yeah is yeah yeah Staten
Island I think it's called yeah come on
guys we love you Staten Island Joe G
good friend of mine Pete Davidson come
on we like you it's a standard
joke uh all right have you ever almost
died no you going by and beating up
people that jumped you and you've never
I've never been a beat up unconscious
nothing like that no this is good deed I
like this answer yeah what happened with
crack I just smoked it and loved it yeah
it's like a it's an upper yes upper it
gets you real it's similar to
Coke I guess it's faster it's faster
it's faster Coke yeah and it just makes
you feel Euphoria yes I think because
when you snort it you have to wait for
the coke to come down your throat and
absorb yeah and if you inhale it you get
it right away unless you know like some
people they do it and they right away
they run to the water and they put water
in their nose to make it flow flower oh
sure what about PCP whenever I read
Greg's books I'm surprised that yeah
funny La has PCP those a lot of a lot of
um PCP in our neighborhood and
cigarettes dipped in it and stuff New
Ports what yeah there you go what I
thought PCP was like a stronger lstd no
tell me P PCP is more like a elephant
tranquilizer oh it like calms you down
yeah and then you dip your cigarette in
there they will dip
um um mentho Menthol they will dip it
like $5 dip $10 dip or the whole dip the
whole okay so how much of it is like
micro
penises five gr and did you try it yeah
I've done it and it just relaxes you I a
very very violent person yeah like you
it makes you very violent that they
really have to hog you down yeah like
you could fight 10 cops it's not chill
no man if you're like a SI 6' Five Guy
muscles yeah you could take on 20 C by
yourself wow so it's like the Incredible
Hulk yes cigarette but if you're one guy
taking down one guy it's over that's
crazy cuz it's just like hacks your
adrenal system you go you get real fight
flight it's sad because we had a
mechanic in our neighborhood named Eli
and um he was like the best mechanic in
the neighborhood like he'll fix
everybody's car like he he didn't have a
uh auto shop he just go to your car and
yeah he'll spend all day fixing your car
this guy was on PCP while he was doing
the cars yeah I remember my friend hired
him to do um his his Volkswagen Bug to
fix a transmission and um somebody
passed by smoking PCP and then get him
some and he stood like this holding the
wrench for like 3 hours
whoa he never fixed a car again no he
never fixed the car he stood there for
that long just like this so is he
tripping tripping bro visuals I don't
know what he's seeing but he's not
fixing the
car car is still broken I remember my
friend um you know how weirdo Yak has
those songs sure my and then my friend
made up a song um like um come on baby
Light My Fire yeah and my friend was
always on something he was always he was
into the doors and he was like he'll
just make up songs to whatever's going
on yeah and he saw Eli right there he
goes come on Eli fix my tire come on Eli
fix my tire the the time to hesitate is
through you and your brother smoking goo
come on Eli fix my tire wow singing
right next to him too while he's all
s yeah man a lot of my humor comes from
my neighborhood yeah how and then how
did you kick crack that's that's one of
the most addictive things in the world
isn't it father Greg put me in rehab he
did it yeah oh we're back full circle
yeah father Greg came to my house and he
found out that um I got into a fight
with four people and I bit somebody's
ear off and and things are bad for me so
he he drove me to live again recovery
homes in sagas
California with Brother
Juan shout out Pastor Juan Jesse higera
and he helped you yeah wow I was in a
rehab with I think like 50 men that were
from all over the LA area heroin addicts
alcoholics all all our religions our our
rehab with non- denominations so every
Sunday or Saturday we will get in
different cars and go to our respective
religion like a Jewish guy he went to
his church and we had an Armenian guy
who went with he was Catholic he went
with our church and then um Everybody
mandatory had to go to this church in
Burbank called um Burbank Community
Church with Pastor Jones okay he was a
crazy pastor bro this guy he was a very
devoted Christian he was so
funny you know like um he will do his
his um sermon and then he'll He he'll
throw in in the mix our our rehab like
we're sitting on the side you got to
jump for God the way these men jump for
crack he goes he goes you got to focus
on the Lord keep all your focus on the
Lord and then he'll like like he'll like
start talking about how Universal
Studios you know and movies takes you
takes you away from your focus and you
start going this one way but now you're
watching Rambo all day it takes you away
from your yeah so you'll talk bad about
Hollywood but we're like but I love
Rambo
yeah yeah Pastor Jones and what was it
rip okay so rehab they get it out of
your system but what did you take away
that helps you stay off of it well every
day in the rehab it was like being in a
living in a college dorm I guess but not
College Community rehab yeah so at 8 in
the morning man we will get up and we
have like a morning inspiration where
the guy that runs the play he'll do a
quote and do like a 30 minute speech
about a quote like his own set list and
then we'll go have breakfast and then
we'll go to a bunch of meetings and then
more meetings
NA meeting AA meeting anger management
stuff like that and yeah and then some
people were working in their GED and
then we have gym then will clean the
whole area the place that that's the
part I hated the most the cleaning the
cleaning I'd always I always always I
would always pick a rake and stand real
far away and pretend I'm raking with no
rake cuz nobody saw me I would just be
like this
talking
I can't I'm so glad you got clean though
that's really impressive everything
you've told me is so impressive I was in
rehab with a
guy named um Jesus kintana we call him
we call him
chewy he was
like I don't know man he was like I look
at the men that were there and they were
my age now and but their life was all
beat up man their life was pretty much
done me I I feel like I'm in my PR time
I feel like the the future awaits you
know like there's still
hope
and he he he he told me he did like 25
years he said that he like how did you
do 25 years Wow first I did 11 straight
then what then I I was out for 60 days
and I went back I did another nine
straight then I got out they violated me
I did another five but now I've been out
four years so this could been locked up
most of his life yeah he looks at me he
goes I know you're going to get out soon
on a vacation he goes this is a picture
of my wife this where she works I want
you to go over there and give her a big
fat wet kiss with your
tongue what and I'm like 21 years old
right I'm supposed to go kiss a 47 year
old
woman for his request yeah he's like
you're going to be on secretos yeah he's
like 59 60y old
man and then I I just choke around you
know ignore him you didn't kiss her you
didn't go see her he goes then I asked
why you want me to do this CU cuz I know
my wife is messing around but if you go
give her a big weight kiss I'll know
that who she kissed and her and I could
have a big laugh about it and talk and
connect connect and you're a nice guy so
and you're you're single you know my
wife is hot man she's a big she's a
[__] blonde wear a white chick with
big old titties you was telling me she
go you could feel her one the
hug and then I ignored it right then
finally I I saw the where she works one
day I'm I'm going just cruising my
neighborhood and and say okay I'm going
to go check it out and I see her and man
she looks like this like a woman that
used to strip in her early 20s late 30s
and just
retired like she had a body and
everything man like the the kind of
woman you want to have on the outside
while you're doing life you know she was
beautiful and I go oh hello um I I'm in
um I was in rehab with your husband who
chewy who chewy I said yeah and she goes
okay so where's my big wet kiss this was
like a parade of
dudes so I saw her and I and I kissed
her bro and then she really gave me a
kiss and then she went like
this no yeah and then she goes cuz I was
young bro like can see my grandma
bro my hot ass
Grandma so when I went back to rehab I
told him yeah bro give her a big wi k
all right he was laughing this might be
the healthiest relationship I've ever
heard
of we were together for a b we were
together I was with this guy for about a
year living with
him and um he was from a gang in um he
was from a gang in um
La he had a big old ego tattoo he go
asked him where you from I'm from the
original
Clan what and I like what Clan KKK yeah
no dumb
assant and I said oh [__] I heard of
that gang okay this old man bro like old
man he was telling me these stories that
were so unbelievable bro
unbelievable unbelievable like
unbelievable like I guess when you're
locked up
forever like he was telling me that um
he escaped from prison one time just
meditating like he he got into so
meditating like real meditating that
he meditated and had like a Auto Body
Experience where he left the prison for
like two weeks his mind and body and
everything he really felt like he was
gone and I go wow man that's some deep
meditating I done a lot of drugs and
never felt like that and was his body
still in the prison so they didn't
notice they didn't notice but he felt
like he he escaped prison when he was
meditating cuz he got to a meditating
stage that he was just gone for two
weeks he said wow that's incredible he
goes I want to be that high yeah he was
a heroin addict we he was a heroin
addict in rehab because most of the
people were Heron addicts and he was
also the cook so I I kind of like I
became he took me under his wing so I I
became like the cook assistant with him
wow and um you think he was there this
guy would play
Domino's and almost he was you know
people play dominoes and they go like
this um here's one right here is 12
Double 12 this guy will get his his
Domino and from way up
here slam it down
perfectly and say
hog he look at this he said the club you
played in Holland no he he'll say hog
hog wow you're from Netherlands you
know he taught me how to cook Menudo and
um pole what's menudo iudo is like this
this stew made with um cow stomach
lining okay yeah um it challan they eat
it with with marinara sauce and they
have it often yikes Yeah man they have
week that sounds like a sometimes food
it's a Sunday food that should be called
a yeah it's just Tri it's just stomach
lining and Hony wow that's crazy old
chewy man if in peace wherever you're at
yeah wow that's incredible I'll never
forget that we play trivia Pursuit
together he do his answers like all the
way
SLAM here's the last question F I've
enjoyed this so much man you're such a
such a fun person can you tell me a time
in your life you laughed really really
really really really really hard where
you're crying laughing you think you're
going to pee your pants maybe you were
little maybe it was something recently
it doesn't matter but if if you're
crying laughing where are you how old
are you and what happened I'm trying to
remember
this if it was on mushrooms or yeah oh
man what thought going to have a heart
attack you thought you were going to
have a heart attack on mushrooms thought
to have a no I was laughing so much oh
man I was in Seattle
Washington and we had just finished
doing a comedy
show
and we really we I was like having a a
laugh attack already cuz we took
mushrooms and we didn't do no other
other stuff but mushrooms no weed no I'm
sober so and we're at the lobby it was
myself a comedian named Rodrigo Torres
and this other comedian man for the I
wish I could to give his name right now
um Stoner
Rob
and even Stoner Rob only took mushrooms
no way yes and
first of all he wasn't even Stoner Rob
he left another gig to do our gig so he
was not dressed for the weather he was
wearing like sweats like basketball
shorts like shs and boots you no
Converse and no jacket so 20° he was
freezing we see we we we man this guy we
we see a cop a security guard at the at
the hotel and this guy is packing bro he
had like a a side arm AR gun right here
a gun in his pocket we could see they
had a gun in his foot oh God this this
is all for the Marriott you know protect
like he had more guns than the than they
had that the Secret Service had on
January 6 bro like the only person that
I would say had more guns with him was a
security guard and a taco truck and E
called King King Taco that guy right
there man he is a a proud boy Mexican
bro protecting tacos but this guy had a
kind of guns right and then there was
another guy that wanted to party with us
really hard and do other stuff but we
don't we we just get ignoring him right
ignoring him but he keps text he keps um
he's talking to one of our friends and
I'm already laughing but now I start
laughing more because his wife keeps
calling him John where are you right and
he has to pick up the phone every time
and he hangs up but the the caller ID
for his wife was her
butthole stop so was her butthole bro
her butt hole so it was a picture of her
butthole yeah who who so he go who's
that my wife she wonder where the [__] I
was I go then my friend told you better
hang that up but I didn't know that he
was saying you better hang that up so we
could keep seeing the butd hole over and
over so man so I'm already laughing
right and that and then that guy doesn't
know why we're laughing I'm on the floor
and he goes man she then he goes man you
keep and then he goes hang up man let's
see if she calls again so then it keep
watching it over and
over and then she [__] shows up and
goes why are you [__] picking up the
car
man oh my God and she starts
screaming and then the security guard
shows up with all those guns which makes
it more
funnier then like guy go hey hey man um
this is Officer officer sa here we heard
um there's been urb disturbances with a
but hole we want everybody please uh put
your backs down and we want to get to
the bottom of this C we need to do a
lineup whose butthole is this yeah he's
doing that
he's doing the voice but he's also doing
the you know from the police
show yeah yeah yes
yes he law and ordered you yeah oh my
God over a butthole so then um she
leaves and then the [__] keeps coming in
man
again but didn't know I didn't I never
got to see the photo but he was the one
that was we just kept laughing cuz he
turned around he goes bro this guy look
at the screen but never got to see it he
saw it Oh my God but man we just
couldn't stop laugh I will never forget
my like I was
like you thought you were going to die I
thought going to die like so you have
almost died I was di I was di laughing
like those um those laughing hyenas from
that cartoon movie from back in the day
yeah yeah yeah lion Kake the one of the
rabbits no oh man um
not Lion King yeah they were laughing
till they died right oh no no it was the
one with um that comedi Roger Rabbit
Roger Rabbit yeah those hyas would laugh
themselves to death that was almost you
that was me man I really couldn't stop
breathing bro I thought I going to die
my eyes were watery and I felt like I'm
never going to laugh this much
again that was a great one what a
classic fipe hang up bro let her car G
she keeps calling why not just look up
the photo I
say go into the context that is
incredible you are incredible where
you're on tour where what are we going
to plug yes I'm going to be in um Lille
Kentucky okay Louisville Louisville or
Louisville they say it Rhymes louu Louis
Kentucky the place that makes the
Louisville Louisville strugg slug
Sluggers which you got to keep in your
trunk with a catcher mask yes for the
police and I'm going to um the
shipwreck tour with him practical jokers
okay and steo and the Eric Andre this is
great and I'm I'm also on I'm on the
Eric Andre show season five and six sum
of four of of three nice that's awesome
check out the my all my tours at
felipesworld oncom I'm on a tour called
um big fool tour big fool yes I'm also
doing the Netflix the joke in March okay
I have my own show is called Felipe and
friends it's going to be like Felipe's
unsung heroes there you go which I I
have my openers Okay and like one of the
the best openers that you know you know
like sometimes like you say man who do
Louis DK take to open or who do who does
um David take to open yeah who does um
what's his name um so Larry Bubbles
Brown I don't know you know him he holds
the record for being the the longest Gap
between Letterman he did Letterman in
'94 or '96 and then he didn't do it
again till 2007 wow what a strange
record yeah and I know we were counting
that then there's Chuck Bartel okay from
Minnesota very funny guy so you bring
all your openers and do a that's great
I'm doing Netflix as a f it's it's just
me you know he's funny I'm not helping
anybody inclusion you say that like I
want to be on that list you know what I
know like some people are not on a
netfli it's a joke Festival yeah you
know they're not on the show they feel
like they shouldn't be on the show I
should be on that [__] show these
[__] comedians suck but you know what
I I was on the show but you know when it
put out that flyer where it says all the
comedians are going to be on my name was
not on it no list no list I'm not on the
list but I'm on the show then I asked
you know we start asking around well we
wanted to keep it private we wanted to
keep it private why private it's a show
yeah we Tom Brady there going to be the
roast of Tom Brady so you can that a
secret or me a
secret but you know like At first you're
like is that happening is that announced
yeah no no no in the festival in March
yeah but is that a secret did I did I I
never heard about that huh okay yeah
yeah that's happening okay yeah so um
but when that when the whole lineup came
up my name was not in the lineup I'm
sorry yeah so I was was like Netflix is
a
[Laughter]
joke but I will be on the festival I am
on the festival yeah but all all kidding
aside I will not on the flyer but I will
be on the festival that that matters so
much more you want to know where it's
going to be at just go to look for me
fasw world.com yes it is thank you for
doing this man thank for having me would
you say keep it crispy it's how we end
the guests what's up F keep it crispy
without any explanation I love that so
much and you added a what's up fool
thank you so much this is awesome
appreciate
it you made it you made it you made it
oh yeah you made it you made it you made
it oh yeah you made it you made it you
made it
all